yves montand acteur chanteur né le 13
octobre 1921 était aussi connu pour ses
prises de position on est forcément
concernés par cette chose qui est qu'on
appelle la politique même si on ne veut
pas or dix ans ce qui me concerne si
vous voulez c'est que lorsqu'on était un
enfant immigré et qu'on a grandi
vraiment dans ce qu'on appelle ce que
j'appellerais le sous prolétariat et que
la fin du roman se bat pour essayer de
survivre pour manger simplement il
bresse les traces et pas du tout parce
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai un compte en banque
bien garni que j'ai tout ce que j'ai que
j'oublie cette condition là de la vie
ouvrière du grandi à marseille dans une
famille communiste et il gardera ses
engagements en héritage en 1950 il signe
avec d'autres artistes l'appel de
stockholm pour interdire l'arme atomique
six ans plus tard en 1956 il part en
tournée avec sa femme simone signoret
pendant quatre mois en urss
ils sont accueillis comme un couple
présidentiel il dit au kremlin et yves
montand chante sous le portrait de
lénine
[Musique]
à la vie loin des villes ont un débit
ses choix lui seront reprocher tout au
long de sa carrière ma femme et moi nous
avons été boycottée pendant des années
j'ai eu pendant de longues des années
l'interdiction d'aller me présenter
devant le public américain parce que
j'avais signé l'appel de stockholm mais
lors de son voyage en urss c'est la
désillusion yves montand ne pouvaient
plus ignorer la dictature et les goulags
il ne cessera alors de dénoncer le
régime soviétique quitte à se fâcher
avec les membres de sa famille et gens
qui croyaient en tout cas dans cette
forme socialisme là
on y croyait faut bien le dire de façon
presque quasiment religieuse ce tournant
cette désillusion s'inscrit aussi dans
sa carrière en 1970 il joue dans le film
l'aveu de costa-gavras un film anti
stalinien je vous dis mais est ce qu'un
film comme ça ne risque pas je vous dis
non risque rien s'ils sont ils sont
peut-être pas prêt à le recevoir mais il
sera tel qu'il est les années passent
yves montand devient un des artistes les
plus populaires est toujours aussi
engagé en 1984 il est l'invité des
dossiers de l'écran pendant une heure et
demie il répond aux questions des
téléspectateurs alors même qu'on lui
prête des ambitions présidentielles et
son lien avec le parti communiste
interroge encore je n'ai pas changé sur
les choses et linars essentiels comme
mon père m'a prise avant c'est à dire
que je suis toujours comme j'ai déjà dit
répété sa mort elle même parce que je ne
prétends de répéter un texte appris je
suis toujours contre l'intolérance comme
on a dit tout à l'heure contre
l'injustice sûreté surtout contre
l'humiliation et je sais ce que ça veut
dire haut ce que tu es un enfant immigré
yves montand président il y renonce en
1987 et l'annoncent lors de l'émission
questions à domicile
[Musique]